in minneapolis people gathered on easter
sunday close to the spot where george
floyd was killed nearly a year ago the
murder trial of fired police officer
derek shovin
begins its second week this morning and
our jamie yukas is outside the
courthouse where it'll happen
that's in minneapolis jamie good morning
to you
good morning minneapolis is increasing
law enforcement presence on the streets
this week for the trial
george floyd's death affected people far
beyond the city
we even met a woman here yesterday who
drove from
iowa to pay her respects but at the
heart of this tragedy
is a community still grieving
an easter celebration gathered here in
the world outreach for christ church
parking lot
just feet from the memorial marking
where george floyd died
pastor curtis farrar honored floyd
during his easter service it is going to
take the power of god
to get racism out of our human
nature julie jefferson reflected
on floyd's death after the service it's
hard to understand
how one human being could do that to
another human being for
us that goes to this church no matter
what they change around here you're
going to always remember that moment
sammy birch lives not far from where
floyd died back in may
prayer is one after action but together
i mean take action as well
protest teach people
rights from wrong what would justice
look like well
to be treated as one i mean i'm no
different than you you're no different
than me
as the derek chauvin trial hangs over
minneapolis
jefferson says the testimony has been
too painful to watch
i have two sons they're grown and
married now
and i look at that as if that could have
been them
testimony like fridays from the most
senior minneapolis police officer
who was highly critical of chauvin's use
of force on floyd
putting your knee on the neck for that
amount of
that amount of time is just
uncalled for chauvin's attorneys dispute
those claims and
argue it was a combination of health
conditions and drugs that caused floyd
to die
we expect more officers to take the
stand this week including the chief of
the minneapolis police department
who fired chauvin days after the
incident and apologized to floyd's
family
jamie thank you